[Music]
what happened to your shirt
all i ever wanted was a normal life
gave our family legendary power
show me you are strong enough to carry
them
you can't outrun your destiny
i'm not afraid of you
marvel of the ten studios
greedy pg-13
lady here we should be out there
snacking on bad guys
i am a predator i need to be free
you have got to get control of your
aggression we will get hauled off into
area 51.
live in my body you live by my
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it
again you are a loser
eddie brock i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
jesus why me that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not
it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not a crazy man
real vengeful
i will let you eat everybody i promise
oh yeah
eddie you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be
us hey i'm happy for you
i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing some
serious couples counseling
you're a great mom i don't know i'm fine
with trevor
but with phoebe she really keeps me on
the outside
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
[Music]
maybe a new home can be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish he'd get into some trouble
there's still time
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke
and our grandfather left us this creepy
old farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing well i
wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason are you
troubled by strange noises in the middle
of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
have you or any of your family ever seen
a school inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
you guys hear that something's coming
oh city it's like the walking dead
we're ready to believe you
we're closed
[Music]
it was a name that sounded so sweet so
seductive
synonymous with words style
power
but that name was the curse too
i've been a gucci all my life your name
is in the history books wow
you are gucci you need to dress the
party
[Music]
gucci needs new blood it's time to take
out the trash
feel my family
you picked the real firecracker she's a
handful
[Music]
i don't consider myself to be a
particularly ethical person
but i am fair
[Music]
[Music]
can you keep a secret father
son and house of gucci
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
what's to become of our world
[Music]
a boy duncan can i trust you something
yes always you know that i've been
having dreams
about a girl on a radicus i don't know
what it means
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
hey you put on some muscle i didn't no
[Applause]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
[Music]
there's something awakening in my mind
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready
them all
god in heaven
[Music]
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
dad what if i'm not the future of house
of treaties
a great man doesn't seek to lead he's
called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
[Applause]
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
only together can we stand a chance
it's time
[Music]
there is only one question that matters
do you swear on your life
that what you say is true
[Applause]
my father told me my life will be
blessed with good fortune
i'm married
i was a good wife
and then was judged and shamed by my
country
[Applause]
i say before all of you
i spoke the truth
the most unspeakable charge has been
brought against you
charclegri entered our home
he attacked me the accusation is false
i am telling the truth the truth does
not matter
there is only the power of men
should be settled quietly ain't innocent
i request a duel to the death if you
lose
your wife will suffer dire consequences
one of us has lied let us let god decide
you do not believe me i am risking my
life for you
you are risking my life so you can save
your pride
the penalty for bearing false fitness
is that you are to be burned alive
i will not be silent
we'll meet again
don't know where don't know when
but i know we'll meet again
some sunny day hello i'm johnny
knoxville welcome to jackie three
two one
a lot of people ask what will jackass be
like once we're older
well it'll get more mature
the faster you pedal your bike the
faster the other guy's hand goes back
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything concussions aren't great
but as long as you have them before your
50s it's cool
and knoxville's 49 so we're good
[Music]
can you feel my heart wow
today we're going to do a little
furniture shopping
i've been watching jackass since i was
12 years old
and guess what we're here
[Applause]
we have winners and we have steve a
bunch of nasa scientists right
what did you guys do to eric fail to
prepare
prepare to fail
you still got those million dollar teeth
that's for sure
gee didn't set myself up for failure on
this one
aaron please relax i'm trapped
and you're putting honey on me and
salmon
[Music]
this is it
dresses by ella
here's a laugh this girl fancies herself
a businessman
it's only my love for your father rest
your soul that stands between you and a
life on the street
i have to make a life for myself i'll
sell one of my signature dresses
soon everyone will love my name
to make sure your nuptials are done
properly we shall hold a ball
you shall find a bride
cinderella you don't need to go to the
ball please stepmother i spent weeks
making this dress my future depends on
it
i am your fabulous godmother
do you want to go to that ball and meet
a bunch of rich people who will change
your life
yes i was just crying and singing about
it like two minutes ago then go
you shall oh look at that
this is different okay dad you said you
wanted to be a businesswoman
it's magic time oh me
where's my tail i can't balance without
my crap
hi would you like to dance right now
where did you get that dress i designed
it i picked you to be my princess what
about my work
i don't want a life stuck waving from a
royal box any more than a life confined
to a basement
i have dreams that i have to chase
[Music]
life outside this basement starts right
now
[Music]
the glass any way you can make them more
comfortable no but you just did a whole
thing
even magic has its limits
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on everybody okay they got
a call
said there was trouble in the house okay
yeah okay well you all need to look
around
it's a little wet for practice don't you
think don't the girls have schoolwork to
do
they do their homework tandy's first in
her class lynn and isha are two
now i don't mind you saying we hard on
these kids you know why cause we
are that's our job to keep them off
these streets
you wanna check on the kids let's check
on the kids we got future doctors
and lawyers plus a couple of tennis
stars in this house
the chances of achieving the kind of
success that you're talking about
is just very very unlikely okay you're
making a mistake but i'm gonna let you
make it
watch them hit a few balls all right so
tell me your names again i'm venus
i'm serena
so what'd you think
i wrote me a 78-page plan for their
whole career before they was even born
these girls so great how come i've never
heard them they're from compton
it's okay they're just not used to
seeing good looking peoples like us
she's nervous they could step up
[Music]
maybe if you were to take a few more
steps up just get someplace safe
i think you might just have the next
michael jordan oh no brother man
i gots me the next too
this next step you about to take you're
not gonna just be representing you
you're gonna be representing
every little black girl on earth
i'm not gonna let you down i'll could
you
this world ain't never had no respect
for richard williams
but they're gonna respect y'all
you walk out there with your head up you
are a champion
in the whole world
the most dangerous creature on this
whole earth
it's a woman who know how to think yes
daddy
ain't nothing she can't do
you wanna show them how dangerous you
are
venus and serena gonna shake up this
world
[Music]
venus williams who is your best friend
you daddy
sabina williams who is your best friend
genus than you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
foreign
i may not always love you
but long as there are stars above you
you never
i'll make you so sure
[Music]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is parker joe and i'm with
social services
i need police and paramedics i get a
female doa
i'm your social worker you got a
daughter who needs to get to school all
the time
stop crying into my family i'm trying to
keep ashley from being taken away from
you
i didn't know you're getting out today
dahlia
you're the man who's been looking after
my family huh i'm back
i'd love nothing more than have to come
by here anymore prodigal son is home
caught some chatter on the inside that
might be a real score and take care of
business
we're going in there for the money and
the drugs
i'm worried about ashley i'm also
concerned for you
cops came to see me tell me this isn't
happening again
[Music]
i think you could do a big favor for dad
today
[Music]
this happened here because of you you
got the cartel after all of us
why are you even helping us no one
helped me when i needed it most
they're in trouble i'm in trouble
i've seen so many families the clips
that they're about to follow from
and there's nothing i can do to stop it
you actually
can help people you have an opportunity
to get
something
[Music]
don't have to work for done
if this was your family what would you
[Music]
do
[Music]
there is a weight a man can accrue
this is where all the good stuff happens
the weight created by his past actions
it is a weight which can never be
removed
all in
you count cards right i'm not that smart
bet you win
you need someone to stay cute that's
what you do you run a stable
i'm always looking for a good
thoroughbred
having been sentenced to 10 years in
prison i learned to count cards
how'd you do that
poker is all about waiting check raise
re-raise
then something happens you remember it
this is where all the good stuff happens
they made you the fall guy you need to
back off
you've been around him he's a mystery
and i don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing
this is how it starts does the fleeting
thought
you might want a piece of what i'm gonna
do then it builds
what is that set thing straight
it doesn't matter to me if you did
something bad in your past
nothing nothing can justify what we did
we are each responsible for our own
actions
you know the phrase tilt just like a
pinball any man can tilt
you can tilt
is it possible to know when one reaches
the limit
[Music]
you have to be the strangest poker
player i ever met oh you have no idea
how is this possible
do you know what this place is
your mother angela she's our patient
i've been out of touch with her for
a very long time oh my god
her mind is very active in the
simulation stimulation
she went on a homicidal rampage
this is your chance to ask her why
mom carly you have to go
you have to go
guys please help me out can you hear me
are you sure that you haven't been
having any hallucinations outside of the
simulation
[Music]
[Applause]
demonic possession it can be real
i can't do this you won't end up like
your mother
the vatican has been funding the black
ops unit
now that it's free it won't
stop coming for you
stop right there
[Music]
you